what's up everybody Walter Bonet dziak
here with my regular co-host Ayanna
Wayde and Heather ruse and a special
guest today
it's Brad Jones who's told every serial
so today we're gonna be talking about
our favorite nostalgic serials what
we're gonna do to make this even more
fun is we're gonna blindfold Brad
because yes some experience with trying
different kinds of foods so we're gonna
be doing that for each number and we're
also just gonna be discussing lies or
favorite cereals that's not a bird box
challenge it's a bird box challenge for
people haven't seen bird this is the top
5 nostalgic cereals number 5 I guess the
Proverbs I've only been awake for like
an hour so this is it Lucky Charms
no I know this taste is a Cap'n Crunch
captain ratio Magellan Crunch has been
pushing this cereal since 1963 and his
popularity has been exceptional over the
decades it's the image and paste that
keeps us all coming back famous for not
getting soggy in milk and keeping its
crunch
Cap'n Crunch has been linked to the
infamous Cap'n Crunch mouth where the
roof of your mouth gets a little torn up
when eating too much of the cereal
plenty of spin-offs like peanut butter
crunch and oops all berries have been
around for many years but it's the
original that we're focusing on today
you guys
crunch mouth guess where it cuts your
yeah that's what's happening right now
it's worth it though
no but it's it's all like no I get that
I think that's what kind of gave it away
from I was watching some of the old
commercials yesterday and they really
look like those old Rocky and Bullwinkle
cartoons I think what I miss most about
Cap'n Crunch is like the the commercials
that like we grew up with like back in
the 80s where like cereal commercials
could have villains so they had this I
don't know if they still do the Saudis
anymore like any my know but I think
they do there's a lot of yeah there
would be like Saturday morning cartoon
villains you'd have these grotesque like
milk looking blog creatures chasing you
down to like soggy eart cereal which is
maybe a good thing is that it wouldn't
injure the kids about this I was like
the gimmick for this was like it doesn't
get soggy in milk no matter how long you
leave it my soggy - so the Saudis are
back there real bill they may be you're
a natural so maybe they're not like just
made out of cards I guess I'm already
full number four
okay Cocoa Puffs first hit the market in
1958 these chocolate flavored corn
spheres haven't changed too much since
their inception except a lowering of
sugar content usually milk only serves
as the vehicle to shovel more spoonfuls
into your cereal hole but cocoa puffs
changed the game superior to its
globular cousins plain corn kicks and
fruity flavored tricks this real
Hershey's cocoa variety turns your
boring old milk to sweet sweet chocolate
milk where the brand like the generic
they're just great this is a solid
cereal model
cocoa puffs is one that I did always
light but I rarely would actually get
like if I when it's one of those series
when I whenever I ate it it was because
I was somewhere where that's what they
had if I was getting a chocolate cereal
my favorite was always yes but then it's
great because it's like eating like a
casserole yeah that just makes it even
better like I was a really weird kid
what a surprise so we used to have cocoa
pebbles and we'd wait till the milk got
soggy and like it got soggy to look up
your aqua tea and then stick it in the
freezer for five minutes
and let it look like ice cream cold
mashed potatoes
No yes remember freezing it
distinctively really did that a couple
of times and it was like what I'm
getting a huge sugar rush and we're only
two cereals it was like eating it with
spoiled milk that way the texture of the
milk matches the machinist our match
kids cereal
I haven't tried it yet but I got a box
over the dole sure I'm going for a
warhead cereal now that's number three I
know I'm like I'm trying to figure out
based on the spell because it's like
heavy waffle crisp was first sold in
1996 the original commercial showed a
group of elderly women making the cereal
waffle bit by waffle bit in a factory
that children tried to break into to
steal the formula the corn based cereal
has a maple syrup flavor to it this was
my personal favorite cereal as a kid
unfortunately it was discontinued in
August of 2018 better get it while you
are still able to find it my mom used to
get Sam's Club boxes of waffle crisps
for us so like this is as soon as you
poured it I was like all memories
memories literally like me on a Saturday
morning watching cards I didn't grow up
with because like I think the cereal
came out when I was much older like I
want to say this was past 96 when it
came out okay so like it was that would
have been around when I was maybe
eating as much cereal during the morning
but I remember having this sometime so
so when I was a kid basically we just
had to like just stuff waffles into a
bowl the hard way before they made it
way more convenient my grandma would
have this sometimes with my animal would
just keep a cabinet full of cereals this
was usually we just always got the worst
cereals for you my mom would just be
like most sugary cereal it may believe
and they smell like they smell like
straight-up your shovin maple syrup
right but they don't taste like it do
you guys remember when they were allowed
to actually just put the word sugar in
the titles of the series continued in
August we're not gonna make you another
nice two-year-old when it's not tastes
like buttery crackers for my palate fun
number two
waiting for just a delicious bowl of
chili well there's no beans
is this a pop-tart crunch oh yeah that's
a real thing these are less sweet than I
remember mm-hmm remember the last time I
had these at a time with eggnog is it
Cookie Crisp was originally introduced
in 1977 20 years later General Mills
bought the trademark and changed the
recipe much to the dismay of diehard
fans personally I think the most
memorable part of the cereal is some of
the advertising growing up in the 90s it
was impossible to avoid the howl of
Cokie crisp from chip the dog Cookie
Crisp was younger because I just like
softer cookie instead of like the mini
Chips Ahoy uniform than I expected I
definitely had these don't eat them with
Coors Light sounds like a great idea
it's really which mascots of Cookie
Crisp did you guys he was by himself for
a little while and then he got a
sidekick in the sidekick who started the
cold yeah he greatest thing there was
yeah
cookie cop and cookie crook yeah
that's what I grew up because it was a
cereal that needed its own hamburger had
to change it with some kid got 20 years
for actually trying to steal these are
really nice after this really sweet
waffle crisp I'm surprised they haven't
tried it with like different kinds of
cookies like a peanut butter chip cookie
yeah oatmeal raisin I remember being
like a sprinkle one for holidays I
thought I remember I don't know
Christmas good I remember that like
seeing it at least having give her
colors a holiday instead of like
chocolate chips with like sprinkles it
probably was cuz like I mean he'll
there's a donut cereal now nothing would
surprise me and the number one bet
nostalgic cereal is sugar crash car
who wants to be my music with the French
toast there aren't many things more 90s
than French toast crunch an offshoot of
cinnamon toast crunch it was introduced
in 1995 and became very popular it was
discontinued in the United States in
2006 but by popular demand was revived
in 2014 and is still available in
limited capacity
I haven't eaten any in years and I'm
ecstatic to finally reacquaint this
cereal with my taste buds
[Music]
everyone loved french toast crunch yes
like I was like a fan of cinnamon toast
crunch back in the day I'm gonna come
out with this like I'll try this and
then I just went crazy for it my
cousin's loved it
a lot of my friends always talked about
french toast constantly talk about in
the 90s we loved two things French toast
crunch and ace of Biggie's I like the
theory that because it was still Wendell
the chef on this right on the box
that the two other chefs from the older
Cinnamon Toast Crunch boxes who later
they disappeared no one knows what
happened could possibly have been made
and turned into French toaster image
it's one of those series like cinnamon
toast crunch that transit the
transitions pretty well into like those
cereal bar forms that they make like
semi toast crunch does where it's cereal
on the counter NOLA bar version of a
secret no I'm not layer
[Music]
I feel energized too but data I might
have a heart you're so high on sugar
yeah it's the only thing that got me up
in the morning I tried to keep it you
know like not too much in mind for the
other ones because I really want
honestly I like them as an adult I get
it man Jeremy well and I switched over
for this one to the almond milk the
vanilla flavors of the almond milk
really vanilla almond I rent it with
French to enhance the French toast yes
so you know try it with some little
almond milk you do not need more sugar
half a stick of butter some maple syrup
oh my god in here that doesn't really
threw me off at night number one was
like cream of wheat by Wawa well you
guys leave some comments about what are
some of your favorite cereals from back
in the day or what do you still eat I
think a lot of kids that are now grown
up and maybe around our age still need
cereal a lot I feel like that's kind of
a throw
people still do if you're my dad you can
be a baby-boomer instead of popcorn bowl
so go ahead and try that baby but anyway
thank you guys so much for watching this
is a lot of fun bread this is good they
were doing like top 5 best sodas or
something well thank you guys again for
watching really appreciated
I'll check back next week for a brand
new episode of top 5 I could check us on
the social medias header where are you
at you can find me on Twitter Instagram
or Twitter I stream on Wednesday nights
ion where you in I'm on Facebook Twitter
Instagram I'm sure you can subscribe to
me at youtube.com slash stoned gremlin
productions follow us on Facebook at the
cinema snob at Instagram at the cinema
snob and face book facebook.com slash
the cinema snob Brad tries that's oh
yeah my stomach loves me for this the
one ship challenge video everybody will
talk you next week thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you